you
hello and welcome to our live show is
this working well it was a little bit of
a bumpy start here some hardware issue
but I think it's okay so hello and
welcome to all of you in the chat um yo
so let's get going play some blitz I'm
looking forward to it yeah we have the
world championship match going on cons
wide against kayaking we can have a look
like in the like halftime or so just to
have an idea what was going on I have no
idea myself let's get going trying to
request a five-minute game not sure how
much pull traffic i will get playing
machete wow it's a funky flag seychelles
okay so let's go before against machete
looks like we get a Sicilian the night
off okay so we get the h 3g for line and
yeah this I think is a is a pretty good
line for white let's see what machete is
up to I think before I even hello it
looks kind of funky wit yeah this is a
theoretical line e takes as g5g you form
yeah why do you think it's a bit better
here in this position you will see what
machete is doing my ideas you form for
better ending
this has been played in in a game I
don't quite remember who the players
were bit wide was a bit more comfortable
yeah I wonder if he moves the knight
Knight to f6 was played in that
mentioned game um I wonder if there's
something else f5 maybe can you play the
Cairo or London I should i maybe should
should write that down here and make
some note here on it so machete is
thinking and now yeah there's 96 11
possibility or just um just Bishop g2
yeah I think 96 was my main point Bishop
d7 probably will take be seven days
bishop to c6 but i have Bishop g2 so i
might be able to i yes bishop he has
bishop c6 may be still yeah I cannot go
nite b7 that was a weird idea so um what
to do I can't threaten on b7 by castling
let's say let him take and then how
someone cover the beep horn it's not
that easy actually can go Bishop now we
cannot know maybe this is an idea yeah
just just through this threaten light b7
now
you're not going to play this left us
laughs I mean it is it is also not that
easy to ya to force let's say the
opponent into so what to do here look
you 1,000,000 support the night but
caracarno london system air the cairo is
quite possible to happen people will
play for and at some point yes so here
the night doesn't have many squares do i
go Bishop f4 here or what do i do I can
also play be five in this position hmm
there's also be five interesting or just
Bishop f4 to to cover to cover that if I
go Bishop e3 route d8c five and as he's
got d5 then which I don't like I can
also play g5 immediately and push him
away that's actually interesting ask him
where he wants to go yeah now that
they're I should have played there
quicker actually where is he going here
we can go to eat but that's not a
fantastic square I will trade and play I
can play Bishop f4 actually it's
possible maybe but actually I think that
taking is good and now just him so
that's easy for me to develop here yeah
I can do this knight c6 but I have up to
seven I wonder I wonder I can also play
this this is maybe also interesting I
should have started double duty cell ok
anyway this is still a good position I
shouldn't worry all that much maybe okay
maybe 93 I would like to play yeah yeah
hmm he's got this now he's got this
efore idea
I would like to play a five in this
position and then he can activate this
mmm I should have played it differently
a little bit
hmm how to do the same may be here so I
didn't expect that at all is that good I
thought I would just attack the paneer
and 95 coming that's strange I wasn't
expecting this move at all
hmm I can just take it for Herod and now
what to do here take it I can just take
it and King III pushes black bag oh I'm
really I'm blundering this born in one
move how bad can you play time morning
oh my god that was so unnecessary that's
you that's how you spoil the winning
position I'm amazing amazing just
blunder this in one move wow wow wow wow
ok
check
so threatening ig5 eyes got age 6 cm
stupid hmm clap and that was extra a
stupid game with a pretty simple way to
win in this ending and i blundered c4 in
one move pretty awful check check
now enter all this works unfortunately
for him clap you know yeah I mind what
what kind of [ __ ] is there just
blunder c4 and won't move yeah I mean of
whatever you just play whatever here
okay anyway so let's get a new game Oh
your scanner is always a little bit
tricky it's quite clear so I try the
London system as you as you requested
here we go Bishop d6 wow that's really i
mean the double pawn I'm not sure that
this is helping all that much if I take
on d6 the double bond could actually be
quite useful for black so I just wait
him and see what he's doing if I could
bishop ok it's not trade everything here
I don't want to trade everything after
possible Bishop d3 and d4 hair paypal
donation for opening requests that
sounds like a very a capitalistic idea
but maybe it works I one day ever should
actually play Bishop h4 in this position
and ask him about this pin I think I'll
do that
quindi aight i think yes we go queen da
da sooner or later
so let's see him Queen d8 now maybe yep
so how to do this here there should be
seven is what he wants to do let's see
him again first of all making play this
move c5 probably not and maybe just
centralized yeah I wonder if he is going
for d5 here no okay I'm doing some
getting some more space wait thing I
should probably bring the Queen away
from the sea file and the hello Ben
gambit and nobody requested the
Halloween gambit like two weeks ago
which would be fitting and i actually
won't play that it's just too bad i mean
this is an entirely entirely wrong
opening that that doesn't work at all
due to numerous lines actually
not sure if it is totally losing but it
is bad for white one thing I know I
played relatively quickly
okay so he strikes in the center but
isn't night h4 interesting let's do it
directly shooting form okay so i can go
d5 here the fright fox defense what the
heck is that I actually don't don't
believe this exists and so night at five
Queenie six probably the d5 you might
take the spoon you see threatening
anything not really so let's play a
useful move didn't quite see if night f5
f5 is doing much
the right fox defend the city for f6d
for king of seven oh my god no I don't
think so yeah I wonder what Black should
be doing him that's not easy m-maybe no
night h5 don't really see this doing all
that much hmm okay if I take with the
rook I have some unprotected pieces this
is what I don't like here but other than
that it's pretty okay mm-hmm so night f5
against queen is six not doing much mmm
yeah I can go see five here on time
Bishop g5 that's extremely sharp let's
do it yeah this should be very good
night at five to e6 it's hard to prevent
actually Bishop g5 maybe anyone I've got
Bishop c4 yeah it looks good so night
a59 to the 60 is he going he's going
Queen g5 there
my night is hanging and this night is
also hanging so maybe Queens III which
would actually blunder deform okay hmm
it's a little bit a little bit weird
time morning I am ok it's a bit on bit
lame I hope it's good I mean the
position should be really good for wide
unless I'm overlooking some kind of
tactic that's such a huge hole on d6
which folks basically all pieces them or
is there some wiki tactic I don't see it
yeah I could take a six but I know what
you're saying but this is not the number
one priority am taking a porn on the
edge of the board I failed at least
if it takes h3 i will take d5 that gets
rid of the poor to ship them check black
for fits on time yeah couple of extra
night see at the end difficult but I had
a good position out of the opening that
Bishop d 6 i'm not sure about this was
such a good choice yeah my opinion about
the match yet this wasn't them all that
thrilling yet we had to pretty tedious
games and i think them currently
contested one is also not very exciting
very technical positions which is
probably not too surprising considering
how both players usually play the other
hand you still hope for some some more
some more fireworks I mean there's more
in chess than trading to some ending
after 12 looks um but yeah that's that
that's what you have to deal with it's a
little bit um comparable to one of those
that say matches and in football or team
sports we're especially football so I
mean or soccer for the Americans is a
low-scoring game you usually only have
23 goals per match and this is kind of
comparable I think to to the match
situation here
two teams with extremely good let's say
technical setup play against one another
and it's difficult to score goal and
both sides feel like if they yeah get
scored against um they yeah there would
be would be hard to come back with the
top form Bobby Fischer beat them yeah
that's 40 years ago when when Fisher
played more than 40 years ago I think
this comparison is not particularly it's
very difficult Fisher of course was an
enormous talent but if you would like
put him in a time machine from 1972
against those guys he would use that
match pretty badly without the theory
and everything but from a chess
potential point of view it was of course
excellent so zara zara marlena get a
bingo game but I didn't think I had
something in particular request 32
against before or was there Slav request
I don't know maybe ignored a route west
left us laugh I don't know yeah what
what you said yeah cat rocket with a
heart out signal on team in the 90s yeah
yeah it's a little bit like that yeah
perfect defense em and very difficult to
to score against and this is a bit of
them the problem both players are also
stylistically speaking I'm pretty close
to one another and
g3 yeah I think six night you FOIAs
bishops you will now so that doesn't do
all that much yeah we won't see a bank
or gambit in the world championship
match that's pretty close pretty clear
the only situation where this is
possible would be some kind of must-win
situation near the end of the match
Quincy one not the CM seems you want to
play Bishop to h6 ok ok let's do this
first I'd like to play you five here
yeah what did track ourselves on suggest
against benko would be interesting he
usually avoids it this is the funny
thing he usually plays 393 yeah I'm
closing the center here this is why I
didn't mind the trade of the dark
squared bishop or that much we often get
this closed center type of position okay
bring this around yeah white is playing
for FY y en disposition I wonder about
night h5 if this is something that would
help hmm not sure him bishop f3 I might
have to go back I don't think so there's
a remark and then check that in the bank
receipt XP 5 a 6 b 6 is very unpleasant
I actually believe that black is very
good there I mean not like isn't got an
advantage but I think black is very okay
I don't fear that line at all really
absolutely not maybe I'm seeing this
made my perspective is wrong but I I
don't I don't fear it at all and
meanwhile some of my opponent is playing
quite well hmm something wasn't right
what I did here
hmm i don't like to play f6 and looks
really happy passive okay what if I
remind him about the pawn not sure I
mean I understand that the bank was just
too risky for the top level absolutely
clear it's a porn down yes weepy
encouraged me to take the point I'll
take it I liev on a pony at least for
this slightly cramped position yeah so
let's go back defense defense yeah let's
see okay i guess i go here i wonder i
think I'm threatening night she for him
then Queen g5 maybe yeah it's not a
threat but one thing is I want to I want
to fall not too much oh really well it
helps me to trade and that helps me to
win a bond I'm taking this now it's
doing stuff that's really helpful oh wow
is frustrated quite clearly yeah White's
position was certainly okay but okay
White's position was certainly okay yeah
the last proper gambit played in a World
share World Championships came wow it's
difficult
check check check I'm not sure check
like the King's gambit or something
check checkmate it's probably been a
long while there certainly have been
very sharp very sharp games he wrote to
me nya see any idea what that means game
started ok playing the next game here
against Jerome there was a request for
the London so why not own it worked the
last time as you roam early Queen to be
6 yeah just develop mmm yeah well the
bishop is not outside of the pawn chain
so probably the capture isn't all that
bad I can get the rook out of this
immediate idea of B form so how to do
this Knight f3 years probably night h5 I
don't want that I just develop him long
term oops New York Athletic Club I don't
think he meant that somehow open-pit
that summer I don't think he meant that
um ok Knight e5
I don't know if that's doing all that
much yeah maybe night sorry bishop c6
yeah I don't think I want this Bishop
Pam and me well maybe he maybe he wants
to take I'm not sure ok i can click with
the bishop but adds not ideal I don't
like my 95 decision with the hindsight I
was going back I can also take now on c6
and play the movie form and wonder if
this is an idea or if or if this is
ridiculous but this end then f three
years or maybe assess something before
would actually activators his Bishop
okay's on the way to a forum yeah so i
probably have to be ready to take it and
thats it seems like black plant is
valium it looks like you played this
quite well ok I'm have to I mean I don't
maybe not but I want to do something
just don't want to sit around how to do
this year some e 5 or this night a for
is annoying I could cover it with Ruby 1
i'm not quite sure how I can make any
progress here in this situation
if I've is probably wrong I don't know
what my bishop is doing him it's still
it feels like this is not doing at
anything here maybe I can bring it over
to e3 I'm not sure that it's doing more
they offer to be perfectly honest but
currently i'm going to sure how to
proceed in this position tripti sound I
don't know I don't mind this straight
but I'm really unsure this is
strategically quite complex and I'm
really absolutely not sure how to do it
taking on f4 actually taking on f4 and
then g3 could be an idea yeah not that
much hmm doesn't do that much h4 here
you will take only 3
home
hmm g3 actually weakens the H porn
nope come on this is just verson in my
position if I do something there so
let's stop this idea Black is definitely
fine yeah when he sees just having the a
more active position do you just want to
draw it seems she just wants the draw
and the draw i saw ever really name I
mean the position is really not anything
for me but but just making a draw I
don't I don't know it's a bit lame for a
live show maybe I can do something here
Bishop 2g 6th interesting if this is his
idea I'm trying night you for tf2 and
then maybe g3 this is the time situation
is a little bit a little bit tricky
always taking that's that I didn't
expect to happen
night coming to the 60m but time morning
if i take it's probably ok for him
because my king is not well placed on e
2 a.m. he can take with a king actually
this is possible I didn't expect this
one but it is a good move probably sis
fighting 44 here not not a good game
really played this quite well
you
yeah the London system i mean i don't
know i don't i think i like a little bit
of knowledge there to actually i mean
every just had a worse position here for
a quick quite quickly f2 even works yeah
okay i roped you to even wins I think oh
maybe not it's close though
that's also losing but cat that wasn't
through that wasn't the best now I'm
completely fine check check check draw
two offered check check check check
check check white forfeits on time yeah
that happens it happens what can you do
nail plate as well I mean up to a
pointer as you can see the final
position but he plate this plate this
quite well I didn't have anything I mean
here yeah I felt this should be quite
okay but any blacks pollution is very
solid again I never understood why the
London says system got any sort of
popularity because it's just nothing at
all okay I mean I didn't play it play it
well but there's really little incentive
to play it
now that's er that's a funny question
here by a by a user gizem if I have any
sort of memories of playing the European
clock cup 2011 in in oh gosh gasps
Latino in Slovenia of course I do I
visit this this place basically once a
year now it's my permanent summer
holiday have you been there as well or
have we been there together okay cow
Kailash wash away I am that was a
request for the chiro but you saw what
what happened here with them the bloody
London system I got killed with white
okay so what do we have here against wgm
de lis glue the sideline in the Indus
axillary n who is that by the way
harmonica such goers she never bothered
to update that she's a GM now for a
couple of years very strong player I
mean like the overall GM title sure I've
been to Poland yeah I've played last
year played the open tournament in rod
schlub was a very very good a good trip
very enjoyable the only drawback was
something that is not about the
destination it was just inconceivably
hot I mean we were really really
suffering quite badly from from the heat
wave
I've only been to there's a question
you've ever been to America had only
been to New York for a couple of days in
1999 so already a long time ago I'd like
to go again but it's a currently nothing
special planned so why just given up the
e4 pawn here for attacking chances and
it feels dangerous really yeah and
that's five tix there there sir I quite
a number of pieces down on my position
yeah this one for example I came let's
trade some stuff yeah okay something
like f6 looks dreadful I cannot go 95
and write a threatening pawn to f6 I
wonder if I should take it Tim let's
take it I pretty tough to play
especially in the time control like this
now what is a strong attack him
quinte exam may be Queen c8 on twin c8
twin goes back home tough really really
tough maybe I have to do something ugly
like that just to get out of this this
is bind and now Quincy eight yeah I
don't know what this actually is doing
she might go nite a form yeah I know it
looks bad maybe not not for a computer
but for a human player this looks like a
complete garbage yep I'll take
everything yet I'm actually we have a I
almost I take the the bishop now I think
objectively I should be okay but there's
all kinds of mayhem possible
yeah it did it did sounded like that
yeah that that visiting the the match in
New York wasn't all that all that great
with some some people mentioned there
were some problems with it like you
couldn't see all that much and and and
things yeah this is this is not so
unusual quite often the best experience
is simply at home okay I'm what to do
here maybe just Quincy aid putting this
in a pin again it's however not easy to
say how I can actually make use of it
look H for something maybe here at night
I made however my position is rather
passive after that is she threatening
something h4 h5 maybe hmm
you
ah
time morning yeah yeah why probably win
somehow this is super difficult to play
there is no world championships next
year would be strange they have one
tournament / / every two years and one
match let's aim every two years each sex
coming or what if I get in babe Bishop
h6 myself and probably winning no this
one so this will be the time aslam
biggest issue in the position is okay
probably okay I want actually trapping
the rook took me a moment to see that
I'm event in the rook trapped that's
lucky it's still not so easy rook c4 and
she will get to the seventh ring and I
have no time cap yeah that that's
actually Oh interesting
check bloody murder him wonder what did
waterway is stare and then she just
blundered into it anything matter those
are the worst moments white still
retained a good position Nev still no
time cap I don't know that when what did
i do that i have no idea
check and no time to look for stuff like
that check check check check okay
position is a draw pretty easy one
actually check check check white
forfeits on time and that's nothing to
do i mean i don't culture I couldn't
even know for a draw I was down on time
the whole little game hello okay so um
gothic to us did I ever use a chess
program to win an online game um know
what I did what I did like once or twice
um I had at times i looked up lines in
any book yeah i really did that not for
for any games on video but like years
ago when i was practicing openings and
sometimes had to book near me and like
what was said when i was looking it up
you can consider the cheating if you
want but i did this once I don't do that
again because it doesn't really or
anymore it doesn't really help that you
should look it up afterwards
so do we have a new game game started
gee Rome again okay I need to reventon
yeah I would probably do Christmas
streams probably probably I will do that
yeah some of that recently was
recommended in a book here it looks
really weird what that's good oh so
you're telling me that d 5 is no good
down that's strange yeah the chat is
quieter than usual i think the world
championship match has a has some
viewers okay i'm just giving this pawn
it's probably not maybe not the best but
clap 33 and set off 110 that's crazy I
mean I am NOT saying that this is
understand that the word championship
match attracts viewers but I wouldn't
thought it is that much of a difference
especially considering that the games
are total snooze fests okay um how'd you
get something here may be here 25 that's
interesting ship h3 is that a rule floor
Bishop g4 maybe
yeah I have some compensation here for
sure until I overlooked this move but i
have c 5 now or actually even be five
hmm ok let's go see five
hey yes that looks nice I should have
pretty decent compensation here what is
he doing here with the night
I don't know what what is what is what
doing now
castles I want to take two times on f3
yeah okay so let's take I thought about
this briefly but I felt it shouldn't be
all that good oh sorry verb so take care
right and then root g one is the thing
ok ok ok ok if I play this first maybe
let's play this first
I could have still taken bishop f6 is
covered and what was the first opening
you learn learn to play decent um tough
the same em but here would be for all
right key for 4g for should win my
resign yeah that's the wind was ripped
chief for I'd look pretty risky business
here for white and I don't know i mean
when i started playing chess on i am
startled i played mostly a 1d four
openings I played the Kings Indian but
black and I played the night off because
I looked a lot at Fisher's games and
this was an influence definitely it's
not exactly what most people start with
but it turned out okay I guess yonder
man so we get a Queens gambit declined
here surprisingly normally he placed
some kind of hedgehogs in some kind of
hedgehog and now we got a very classical
twin scam but quite surprised it's a
very unknown and common in combination
of openings
yeah started d for for some reason I
cannot cannot tell you why I mean I
think one possible influence and
probably where the world championship
matches between carbon when Kasparov
they were played at the time when I was
started and they played played mostly
deform and I also liked him cup of
blancas games and so on it kk i don't
know i know it happened it happened like
that so this is a pretty nice position
let's see I can take first night if for
I can just take on c5 ok Knight b6
a year a little bit here he has this
move it's a bit of a shame not ideal now
I didn't play this well it wasn't the
the best possible way to set this up I
still unlike my position but I could
have played it better fairly certain
okay so I got to my god I got this geez
removing yeah now this Sam I could have
prevented that may be and should have
prevented it I can take here though it
wasn't planned but yeah I can do that
another pure coincidence I didn't see
this before yeah I look be one night I
have six check it was lucky Queen d5
rook p895 doesn't work I can take he
aids play a form where I was lucky I
didn't see this before beforehand okay
so um take the eight maybe eight and
take the second pawn maybe Bishop c6
coming
but it's tough to not take the pawn you
know I should take it Bishop c 6 mm I
can go a form the diagonal is a little
bit annoying okay just at exit it's not
so easy 96 you will take on c5 pronate
Knight b6 I mean yeah Knight f6 yeah
plump probably feels like a good piece
distribution for this ending maybe I'm
bishop c6 is good mmm yeah that's a bit
of a shame that's pretty active pretty
active
wow that's it actually so easy Wow I
don't like to play you for yeah but i
would like to break this pin I'm not
sure about Bishop e2 we end this
position it's got nice fire fair does
this kind of stuff is extremely
extremely annoying in quincy to we also
has shoot
time warning that's actually not easy to
play yes I can cover latch five but you
can always annoy me here with Queen
something Queen a three or whatever
next move is Kim Jiwan I guess maybe I
should have played kingi one even Queen
d2 a some kind of possible okay now I
can actually cover this stuff Oh sg5 has
idea oh my god oh shoot I should have
gotten out of this probably earlier g5
no 95 check 25 now is a threat actually
quite good check yeah still annoying oh
it probably was a mouse slip
just really feel I'm the slowest player
on earth checkmate okay so I won this at
the end that was tricky extremely tricky
all of the Sun Wow okay so and before
i'm closing this stream i'm going to
have a look at the game wow he said all
that George it actually looks quite
interesting
is it a draw therefore I was potentially
attackable hmm yeah i'm not i'm not
really able to do a full and that is
this year what what happens here if
kayaking doesn't have that much time
yeah yeah repeat or actually saw that's
a funny movie that's a funny move but at
the end here or at the certain at this
current position what's going on here
the bishop is a checked I mean where is
it going if blacks I don't think I can
actually do moves here yeah set in a
leather sport yeah maybe like this I
like g5 I cannot do it d5 and rook g5
this kind of thing that doesn't look
easy that doesn't look easy at all now I
don't want to make for a full analysis
step ICC is covering this with good
commentary who's doing it today was
doing it today mid shag always try for
nan lari Christians and that's great ok
guys I hope you enjoyed the street it
was some some good fighting games i
actually won a couple of rating points
and ok I'm back next week happy to see
you again next Monday thanks for
watching guys bye bye
you